je vais vous raconter une nouvelle
parabole ennuis qu'on la lui ai vu à
bourgoin jallieu judas que reste-t-il à
manger bailleresse aboud pas un bout de
fromage une gousse d'ail et halit de pin
up mais que voulez vous que je fasse
avec ça vingt trois où un mirage asie
amira j'ai vu à murat non non j'ai déjà
ressuscité lazare deux fois ça suffit
comme ça
when you know i'm no 1 ne soit notre
soit j'accepte pierre prépare les
accessoires vous aillez le fond de la
gamelle
oui
roubaix le fromage ans
la mer
seigneur
vous versez dessus
oui seigneur vous laissez mijoter
doucement
oui seigneur seigneur
dans le lancet
vous pouvez manger à et c'est ainsi que
ja résu inventa la fondue savoyarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]